most people think that a fatty liver
comes mainly from drinking too much
alcohol but there's a much more common
disorder called
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
alcohol is just one of the many causes
of a fatty liver but when we talk about
nutritional deficiencies there is one
common nutrient that is nearly always
deficient when you have a fatty liver in
fact if you don't consume enough of this
nutrient from your food you will develop
a fatty liver and that nutrient is
called choline okay now choline isn't
technically a vitamin but it is an
essential nutrient it lives in the
family of the b vitamins because it
works with certain b vitamins like b12
and folic acid but one of its main
purposes is to remove fat from your
liver and if you don't have enough
choline
you will not be able to get rid of fat
from your liver choline is also involved
in brain chemistry and muscle chemistry
and cell membranes and the deficiency of
choline is actually pretty common
there's even a genetic defect that is
also very common with choline it's
called polymorphism it's a common
genetic problem that a lot of people
have and normal amounts of choline don't
seem to
fix a choline deficiency and you need to
take more choline to create the effect
and there's some other very interesting
reasons why you may be deficient in
choline that relate to a fatty liver
now if we actually go beyond some of the
typical reasons
why people develop a fatty liver you
know drinking alcohol consuming carbs
taking corticosteroids tylenol certain
medications solvents petroleum products
viruses consuming too many seed oils
which are high in omega 6 which create
inflammation or of course the fructose
or high fructose corn syrup then we get
to these four things that cause a fatty
liver anorexia nervosa
gastric bypass
parenteral nutrition that is nutrition
fed from an iv
and antibiotics now why would someone
with these situations have a fatty liver
well with anorexia you get severe
malnutrition so not only do you develop
a choline deficiency you also create a
deficiency of vitamin d folic acid b12
and b3 these deficiencies also cause a
fatty liver so malnutrition causes
damage to your liver which then leads to
a fatty liver gastric bypass you're
moving part of the stomach as well as
part of the small intestine that allows
you to absorb these nutrients okay so
you actually create nutritional
deficiencies when you get a gastric
bypass operation now what about
parenteral nutrition well they only put
certain nutrients
in this iv
mainly synthetic but they don't put all
the vitamins that you would need to
protect your liver i mean there's a lot
of data on this it also could be the
amount of dextrose which is a synthetic
sugar that's in here that's going to
create a fatty liver but if you take
that too long you will end up with a
fatty liver
now what about antibiotics what's the
relationship between that and choline
well guess what your microbes in your
gut
make some of the choline and if you
destroy the microbes
you're going to be deficient
so now the next question is what foods
are high in choline well it's the foods
that you may think cause a fatty liver
egg yolks
liver
beef
chicken as well as cruciferous
vegetables fatty salmon almonds which
have a smaller amount and just so you
know a high-fat diet doesn't cause fat
on your liver and if you see a study
that will say that it does
read the study and you're going to find
out the mice experiments that they did
it within that study were not just on a
high fat diet they're on a high fat diet
with a high carbohydrate diet so that is
just a side note so whether you have a
fatty liver caused by
any of these right here
alcohol or carbohydrates or sugar i
would highly recommend to start taking
choline or start consuming the foods
high in choline if you're going to take
it as a supplement i would recommend
taking about three grams a day that will
speed up the removal of fat from your
liver dramatically however if you also
add
the ketogenic diet you can remove up to
50 of your fat within 14 days and if you
haven't seen my video on that i put it
up right here check it out
you